when I was doing when we're doing
Chappelle's Show at the time bill Bert
was bubbling bill burr was bubbling he
wasn't can say that 10 times fast know
the reason why I'm saying it now he was
bubble yeah I saw him in the club he was
like you go see Sir club so you like
this this month I was gonna blow this my
phone's gonna blow but he didn't have
the TV and all that but you know it was
coming
right and we were just repel show we
were making money spell show but not a
lot of money we needed a tour I came up
with the idea of doing a ton rich [ __ ]
to her yeah you know I'm saying in a
rich [ __ ] tore the the to two drawers
at the time with me and Charlie and I
could have ran with the I could have
went to my local but I said not Bill
burr is an animal let's not just do a
show people coming for the novelty of
the show yeah let's give them a show
where this show is fire from beginning
to end and that's what we had done rich
[ __ ] tour I think this is the first
time Bill burr was we would we ran this
shift like a year and a half
Charlie Murphy would um Wow bill burr
you know you know this is funny bill
burr was a feature Wow
and I was headlining and I'll tell you
you know you talk about no excuses
imagine going on every night for a year
behind bill burr thought that there was
no day you could take off yeah you
didn't have a you go out and party get
all [ __ ] up you got a hangover the
next day guess what happened and this
happened to be over times like yeah he
was funny with that white boy the heat
I'm saying and a point I'm making is he
knew his features physical because me at
I was on I really made all of yes it was
just it was pandemonium but bill burr
was a one with the comment cards you
know I'm saying filling him out de bills
I'm like yo you worry about the email
[ __ ] [ __ ] people who become a CEO
forever
he was dude that was doing the email car
and he started building that base yeah
he stopped doing that base and then when
you start on that base
people started riding with you and then
you because then you win like comedian
of the Year in the Montreal Comedy
Festival you gonna build that point he'd
knew what he wanted
early on a lot of people don't Kevin
Hart as much as people want to touch
about Kevin Hart Kevin Hart was the same
situation Kevin Hart was always down
with whatever didn't the newest thing
was was myspace right I remember
has 60,000 followers on Twitter he was
trying but yogi follows now that dudes
out of out of he just on another level
yeah rock star but he planted that and
like you were saying about waiting for
the networks they didn't wait those
people didn't wait so by time the
network's got caught up to them they was
already I was entranced it was not very
ready you know I'm saying and that's
what you said is important you know I'm
saying but like a lot of times in this
business we want to swing for the gate
all the time yeah sometime a base hit is
good sometime a bun is good but you got
to know that yeah that's what separates
two different people now you look at
Bill burr I look at Bill burr 13 years
ago best he was on he was a opening on
our show and then his just doing doing
Madison Square Garden and this is
another thing how stuff's supposed to
inspire you I see that I know how funny
I know how funny is it but it gives you
a sense of Noda you from a place where
it could happen right you know I'm
saying you look at Bill Brady's like
this do we go to st. Claire it could
happen who's gonna put the work in well
you know it's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two options watch one this one